FEMALE SPEAKER: I'd
like to introduce to you
today our speaker
today, Chester Santos.
Chester is the winner of
2008 USA National Memory
Championship.
He's been giving memory
workshops in the Bay Area,
and I attended one of them.
I used to think that
memorizing things is so boring
and it might even
stifle my creativity.
However, after
attending the workshop,
I realized that it would
actually improve my creativity
because it uses both
my left brain and right
brain, plus more.
And I'll let Chester
explain to you some more.
Please welcome Chester Santos.
[APPLAUSE]
CHESTER SANTOS: Thank you.
Thank you for the
introduction, [? Petula ?].
Thanks, everyone, for
have me here today.
I like to start all
of my presentations
out with a couple of
quick demonstrations.
I tried to meet people
as they walked in,
although it was harder
because a lot of people
just flooded in right after
12-- more difficult than I'm
used to.
If you remember meeting
me, if I shook your hand,
gave you my name and
you gave me your name,
if you remember that
happening, please stand up.
OK, this might be tough,
might be a little tough.
We'll see how I do.
If I manage to give your
name correctly from memory,
please have a seat.
So Jared, Antonio, Kay, Alex,
Jeanie, Shao, Hendrick, Erin.
OK, so far so good.
Tiffany.
AUDIENCE: No, I'm just kidding.
CHESTER SANTOS: OK.
You did scare me.
Nick.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHESTER SANTOS: Oh,
cover your name.
Cover your name tag.
Cover your badge.
Charles, Laura, Philippe, Tracy,
Surgen, Alex, Evon, Preveen,
Kevin, Ben, Triv, Alex, Grant,
Zen, Jade, Andre, Evan--
AUDIENCE: Evonne.
CHESTER SANTOS: Sorry, Evonne.
I memorized it as Evan.
Sorry, my bad.
Evonne.
Beta, Olea.
Correct?
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CHESTER SANTOS: Thank you.
So really, that's just
come with training.
I will do one more
demonstration here with numbers.
So Antonio, can you give
me a single digit from zero
through nine?
AUDIENCE: Seven.
CHESTER SANTOS: Seven.
OK.
So hopefully everyone
can see that.
It has to be on
this side, because I
think the live stream is
only picking up this area.
That's why I put it over here.
OK, so a single digit
from zero through nine?
AUDIENCE: Two.
CHESTER SANTOS: Two.
A single digit from
zero through nine.
AUDIENCE: Four.
CHESTER SANTOS: Four.
Right there.
AUDIENCE: Zero.
CHESTER SANTOS: Zero.
AUDIENCE: Nine.
CHESTER SANTOS: Nine
AUDIENCE: Three.
CHESTER SANTOS: Three.
AUDIENCE: Four.
CHESTER SANTOS: Four.
AUDIENCE: Six.
CHESTER SANTOS: Six.
AUDIENCE: One.
AUDIENCE: Seven.
AUDIENCE: Three.
AUDIENCE: Eight.
CHESTER SANTOS: Eight.
AUDIENCE: Two.
CHESTER SANTOS: Two.
AUDIENCE: Six.
CHESTER SANTOS: Over here.
AUDIENCE: Five.
CHESTER SANTOS: Five.
AUDIENCE: Nine.
CHESTER SANTOS: Nine.
AUDIENCE: Eight.
CHESTER SANTOS: Eight.
AUDIENCE: Five.
CHESTER SANTOS: Five.
AUDIENCE: Four.
CHESTER SANTOS: Four.
AUDIENCE: Eight.
CHESTER SANTOS: Eight.
AUDIENCE: One.
AUDIENCE: Another five.
CHESTER SANTOS: Another five.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Seven.
CHESTER SANTOS: Seven.
AUDIENCE: Six.
CHESTER SANTOS: Six.
AUDIENCE: One.
CHESTER SANTOS: One.
AUDIENCE: Three.
CHESTER SANTOS: Three.
Where we at?
AUDIENCE: Two.
CHESTER SANTOS: Two.
Is this a lot of numbers?
You want to do some-- I
guess we can do-- Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Zero.
AUDIENCE: Two.
CHESTER SANTOS: Two.
Is this a lot of
numbers, or does it
look like a lot of numbers?
OK.
Thank you.
Let's see if I remember that.
All right.
Let me know if I
make any mistakes.
Let me know if I make
any mistakes here.
I think it's going to be 7, 2,
4, 0, 9, 3, 4, 6, 1, 1, 7, 3,
8, 2, 6, 5, 9, 8, 5, 4, 8, 5,
5, 7, 6, 1, 3, and 2, 0, 3.
Was I right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
[APPLAUSE]
CHESTER SANTOS: Let me attempt
to repeat that number sequence
backwards.
Let's see if I can do it.
So this would be going from
right to left, bottom to top.
Backwards, that number
sequence I believe
is 3, 0, 2, 3, 1, 6, 7, 5, 5,
8, 4, 5, 8, 9, 5, 6, 2, 8, 3, 7,
1, 1, 6, 4, 3, 9, 0, and then
it was 4, 2, 7 backwards.
Right?
Was I right?
[APPLAUSE]
Just a couple of
quick demonstrations
there to show you it's
possible with just a little bit
of memory training.
So in winning the United States
National Memory Championship,
I actually memorized
the exact order
of a shuffled deck
of playing cards,
all 52 cards in order in
less than two minutes.
I memorized a 132-digit
sequence of computer generated
random digits,
forwards and backwards
in about five minutes.
I represented the United
States in the World Memory
Championship where I memorized
a 1,000-digit sequence and 10
separate shuffle decks of
playing cards in one hour.
I actually starred in an
episode of PBS's "NOVA Science."
That particular
episode was entitled,
"How Smart Can We Get?"
And during that
episode, I actually
demonstrated on a stage
in New York City-- in 2012
is when I did it--
I demonstrated
perfect recall of the entire
United States Congress,
both the House and the
Senate, everyone's first name,
last name, state, district
number, political party,
all congressional committees
on which they serve,
special positions held
within those committees,
and held within
Congress in general.
It was more than
4,000 pieces of data
that I had to have random access
to in my head like a computer.
I realize that those
all seem like it
extraordinary feats of memory.
But in fact, it's all
just come with training.
Training with techniques that
make the most efficient use
of the brain to encode
information so that
makes it much easier to
retrieve that information
when you need it later on.
Really, everyone sitting
in this room today
is capable of doing absolutely
extraordinary things
with your memory.
You just need to learn
the right techniques
and practice a little bit.
My presentation will
we interactive today.
I will have you go through
some exercises that
may seem a bit silly or
unusual at certain points,
but just bear with me,
because I promise you
that what I ask
you to do is going
to help you with your memory.
It's going to make
it much easier
for you to remember things.
So everyone, please close
your eyes at this point.
We will start with a warm up
visualization exercise here.
You're simply going
to do your best
to visualize what
I describe to you.
Just do your best to
see what I describe
to you happening in your mind.
I want for you to
picture yourself
in your current residence,
wherever you're currently
living.
You are in the living room
area of your residence.
And you see there
standing behind podiums,
looking as if they are
about to engage in a debate,
you see Barack Obama
and Mitt Romney.
You thought the debates
were long over in 2012,
but another one's
actually about to happen
in the middle of
your living room.
And although this strikes
you as pretty unusual,
rather than ask
any questions, you
decide to simply hang back
and observe what's going on.
So they begin to debate
there-- just watch this unfold.
You see that the
debate is becoming
more and more heated
between the two politicians,
and at one point, you can
see Romney become very upset.
He's visibly upset at
something that Obama says,
so he reaches behind his
podium to pull out a pie.
He takes this pie and
he throws it at Obama
and it hits Obama
square in the face.
Obama has pie splattered
all over his face.
Obama is not happy
about this at all.
So he reaches behind his
podium now, believe it or not,
to also pull out a pie.
He takes it, he
throws it at Romney
and it hits Romney
square in the face.
What started it out as a
debate has, at this point,
turned into a
full-blown pie fight.
And the politicians
are continuously
throwing pies at each other.
Pie is flying everywhere.
Just see this in your mind
to the best of your ability.
The imagery doesn't need
to be crystal clear,
but just see it as best you can.
You are, at this point,
primarily experiencing
visual images.
You're seeing imagery
running through your mind.
What I'd like you
to do now is attempt
to involve even more senses.
As you experience this scenario
happening in your mind,
imagine that you cannot
only see it happening,
imagine that you can hear
it happening as well.
Imagine that you can hear that
pie flying through the air.
You can hear the pie as it
splatters on the politicians.
Imagine now that you can
eat even smell the pie.
Just do your best to imagine
what that pie might smell like.
Take it a step further now.
Imagine that you walk up
to one of the politicians
and you actually take some
of the pie off of their face.
You feel in your hands--
maybe it feels sort of sticky.
Go ahead now and even put
some of that pie in your mouth
and taste the pie.
Hopefully, you are tasting some
pie there that's pretty good.
Although, some people tell
me it tastes like politician
at this point.
OK, go ahead and open
up your eyes everyone.
Pretty easy, right?
Pretty easy exercise
to complete.
Some people find that
to be a fun exercise.
But what does it have to do
with improving your memory?
In fact, it has a
lot to do with it.
If you were able to complete
that simple exercise,
and I'm sure you all
were, then you actually
have the ability to
remember anything
at all that you would ever want
to remember, quickly, easily,
and with tremendous accuracy.
Here are some reasons why.
Reason number one.
I had you there exercise
your visualization ability.
And your visual memory
is incredibly powerful.
An example that I often cite in
my speeches and presentations
that I now give
all over the world
is a situation that
we've all experienced
at some point in our life,
where you may see someone
that you could
have met years ago.
You could have met
them years in the past.
Oftentimes, as soon as you
see that person's face,
you remember their
face, you know
that you've met them
somewhere before,
but no matter how
hard you try, you
can't seem to remember the name.
That is a very
common experience.
Something else that
happens to us pretty often.
Let's say you go to
a party, and you're
at the party with one of your
friends-- one of your friends
accompanies you to the party,
and your both there meeting
a lot of new people
while mingling.
Two weeks after the party, your
friend that attended with you
is describing someone to you
that you both met at the party.
Your friend says, you know,
that attorney that we met.
He's also a member
of the tennis club.
Given that little bit of
description, a lot of times you
both can easily
pull up a picture
in your mind of that guy's face.
But a lot of times,
neither one of you
can remember what the name was.
That is also a very
common experience.
Why do those two things
that I just described,
why do they happen
to us so often?
It's because when we
are meeting people,
we actually see their
face with our eyes, right.
The face is recorded
into our visual memory,
but at no point are
we seeing the name.
That's why it's much more
difficult to remember names.
Toward the end of
my presentation
today, I'm going to
talk to you about how
you can picture names, how
you can see them in your mind
so that you're better
able to remember them.
That's how a lot of times
I will open presentations
with naming hundreds of
people in an audience
after hearing each
name one time.
It's because I'm
picturing the names
and seeing them in my mind.
Again, I'll talk about
that later, but for now,
note the power of
your visual memory.
If you can see it,
you can remember it.
Second thing to take away
from the exercise with Romney
and Obama is that I had you
involve additional senses
from there.
As you involve more and more
senses in the encoding process
when trying to commit
information to memory,
you're actually activating more
and more areas of your brain.
And your building more and
more connections in your mind
to the information so it makes
it much easier to retrieve it
when you need it later on.
When I starred in that
episode of "NOVA Science,"
I performed some pretty
crazy feats of memory,
and then I trained the host
of the show, David Pogue who
is also a "New York Times"
tech columnist and "CBS News"
correspondent.
You guys have probably
all heard of David Pogue,
I would imagine, in
the tech industry.
I trained him in ways
to improve his memory,
and he was soon performing
extraordinary feats of memory
as well.
Afterwards, a neuroscientist
appeared on the show,
and they talked about how it
was I was able to pull off
those feats of memory, and how
David Pogue was able to do it
with just a little
bit of training.
And they confirmed that it's
because with these memory
techniques that I've
mastered over the years,
and that you'll learn a
little bit about today,
we are actually recruiting
extra areas of our brain
to help us with our memory.
Areas of the brain that are not
normally involved with memory.
We are recruiting
those extra areas
to help us so it makes it much
easier to remember anything
that you would want to remember.
And part of this is learning
to utilize more senses
during the encoding
process to activate
these extra areas of your brain.
Third and final
thing to take away
from the exercise
with Romney and Obama
is that I had you imagine
something happening that
is strange, unusual,
out of the ordinary.
You would not expect
to see that happening
in the middle of
your living room.
And I had you do
that because I want
you to learn to take advantage
of the psychological aspect
to your memory.
And that is, we tend to
remember things with little
to no effort, things that happen
that catch us by surprise, that
are strange, unusual,
extraordinary in some way.
If this were to actually happen
right now at this moment,
if an elephant were to come
crashing through the back door
there right now, through
that doorway, that
came crashing into this room,
and it started spraying water
all over everyone in
here with its trunk,
you might remember that
for the rest of your life
and always tell that story.
And you wouldn't
have to do anything
to commit that to memory.
It would just be stuck there.
Scientists don't
even fully understand
how this works in the brain.
How some things
will just instantly
transfer into your
long-term memory.
However, we do
understand that there
is this aspect to our
memory and that our minds do
work in this way.
And we can actually
take advantage of that
and apply it to things
that would be useful
for us to remember.
Things that would help us
out in school, in our career,
in our personal life.
When you combine those three
principles-- visualization,
utilizing additional
senses from there,
and then you also use your
creativity and your imagination
to make what you are
seeing and experiencing
crazy, unusual, extraordinary,
when you combine those three
principles, it becomes very
easy to remember anything
at all that you would
ever want to remember.
We are now going to
put this into practice.
Without writing anything down,
without writing this down,
you were all going to commit
to memory the following
random list of words.
The word list is monkey, iron,
rope, tight, house, paper,
shoe, worm, envelope, pencil,
river, rock, tree, cheese,
and quarter.
That's the random list of words.
Grant, did you want to
give it a try there?
Was that look of confidence
you were giving me?
Actually, I was just kidding.
I wouldn't expect you to have
that committed to memory yet.
Oftentimes, when I recite
that list of words,
I get looks from
people in the audience,
people are looking at me as if,
come on, man, are you serious?
Like there's no way I'm going
to be able to remember that,
not unless you give me
a lot of time to do it.
But in fact, you are all
going to have that entire list
of words committed to memory,
forwards and backwards, in just
three to four minutes.
And even next week, without
any further review, even
next week, you will still know
it forwards and backwards.
How you are going to
do this is once again
you will simply listen to
what I describe to you,
and you will see and experience
it happening in your mind,
just as you did with the opening
exercise with the politicians.
If you come at this
more as a fun exercise
in using your creativity
and your imagination,
rather than coming at this as
a difficult memory exercise,
then the remembering
is actually going
to come very easily
and very naturally.
So just have fun with this, OK?
The first word was monkey.
So I want for you all to see
a monkey in your mind, OK?
This monkey is dancing around.
It's making monkey noises.
Woo, woo, woo, woo, woo.
Whatever a monkey
would sound like.
I'm working on the
monkey impression.
One day it'll be decent.
But for now, the point here
is to see and experience
this monkey.
The monkey now picks
up a giant iron,
because that was
the second word.
So I want for you to see
this monkey dancing around
with the iron.
And the iron starts
to fall, but a rope
attaches itself to the iron.
And maybe you feel the rope.
Maybe it feels sort of rough.
You look up the rope and you see
that the other end of the rope
is attached to a
kite, and the kite
is flying around in the air.
It's flying around in the air.
Maybe you reach up to
try and touch that kite,
but it's just out of your reach.
Kite was the next word.
This kite you see now crashes
in to the side of a house.
Really see it smash into
the side of a house,
because the next word was house.
Picture that.
This house is completely
covered in paper.
It's completely
A shoe appears out
of nowhere now,
and it's starts to walk
all over that paper.
Maybe it's messing
up the paper as it's
walking on it, that shoe.
This shoe smells
pretty badly, so you
decide to investigate
and see why.
You look inside of
the shoe and you
see a little worm crawling
around inside of that shoe.
Really see that worm.
The worm jumps out of the
shoe and into an envelope.
Really see it go
into the envelope.
A pencil appears
out of nowhere now,
and it starts to write
all over the envelope.
See that pencil frantically
writing all over the envelope,
pencil.
The pencil now
jumps into a river,
and there's a huge splash
for some reason when
that little pencil
hits the river.
The river, you notice, is
crashing up against a rock.
It's crashing up against a rock.
The rock flies out of the
river and into a tree.
Really see it smash
into the tree.
And this tree, for some strange
reason, is growing cheese.
Bet you've never
seen that before.
The tree is growing cheese.
And out of each piece of
cheese shoots a quarter.
A quarter shoots out of
each piece of cheese.
The last word was quarter.
I am going to go through
this again, but very quickly
this time.
And your job is to simply
replay through this story
that you've created
in your mind.
So we had the monkey was
dancing around within an iron.
The rope attached itself.
The other end of the rope
was attached to that kite.
The kite crashed into the house.
The house was covered in paper.
The shoe walked
all over the paper.
Inside of the shoe was the worm.
The worm jumped
into the envelope.
The pencil wrote
on the envelope.
The pencil jumped
into the river.
The river was crashing
into the rock.
The rock flew into the tree.
The tree was growing cheese.
And out of each piece of
cheese shot a quarter.
So you should be able
now to recite to me
that entire random list
of words by simply going
through the story in
your mind and recalling
each major object
that you encounter.
We're going to do
this as a group.
I want for you all to yell
out these random words,
yell them out loud,
on my cue, starting
with the first word
which was monkey.
AUDIENCE: Monkey, iron, rope,
kite, house, paper, shoe, worm,
envelope, pencil, river,
rock, tree, cheese, quarter.
CHESTER SANTOS:
Great job, excellent.
Give yourselves a
round of applause.
Give yourself a
[APPLAUSE]
Nice job there.
A volunteer from the audience
to stand up and recite those
to me, all of them.
Antonio, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Monkey, iron, rope,
kite, house, paper, shoe, worm,
envelope, paper, river,
rock, tree, cheese, quarter.
CHESTER SANTOS:
So after envelope,
what's after envelope?
AUDIENCE: Pencil.
CHESTER SANTOS: You got it.
Good job.
Great job.
Excellent.
Somebody wants to
recite-- somebody's
anxious to recite
these backwards I know.
Erin, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I'll try.
Quarter, cheese, tree, rock,
river, pencil, envelope, worm,
shoe, paper, house,
kite, rope, iron, monkey.
CHESTER SANTOS: Great job.
Give a round of applause.
Nice job.
Great job.
So that technique that
you've learned there
is called the story method.
It is a very powerful way
to go about committing
to memory random
pieces of information.
It's just one of many tools that
memory champions use in order
to perform extraordinary
feats of memory.
Again, it's just about
using the right technique
and practicing a little
bit with those techniques.
That's how we're able to pull
off these extraordinary memory
feats.
If you practice with the story
method and similar techniques,
over time you will
notice many benefits.
Benefit number one, your memory
is going to improve over time.
But this is only assuming that
after this presentation today,
you go out there
and you start to use
these types of techniques
to force yourself
to commit more and more things
to memory and recall them.
If you do that,
your memory is going
to get better because the
brain is very trainable.
Our brains are very trainable.
The more you force your brain
to perform a particular function
over and over again, the
more it signals to your brain
that that's something important
for you to be able to do,
so it will make itself
better at doing it.
The opposite,
however, is also true.
If you never have your brain
perform a particular function,
you're basically
signaling to your brain
that that's something
not too important for you
to be able to do,
so it makes sense
that you will start to lose
that ability over time.
We are all born with
extraordinary memory ability.
We are born with our
brains like sponges.
We need this ability to
quickly acquire and learn
new information in order
to be able to survive.
We reinforce throughout
all of our early years
that learning and memory
is important by engaging
in schooling, in preschool,
kindergarten, elementary
school, junior high,
high school, college,
grad school for some people.
Throughout all of those
years you were constantly
challenged to learn
tons of information
from a wide variety of areas.
You're constantly tested on
your recall of that information
for quizzes, exams,
to write papers.
They say when you
first start a new job
it's a lot of the same thing.
You have to learn
a lot of new things
and recall them in order
to do your job properly.
But then what happens is
we tend to enter this 20,
30+ year period where,
for the most part,
you just start to do the same
things day in and day out.
Everything just
becomes a routine.
You are no longer nearly as
challenged to learn as much
and recall as much as
you were earlier in life.
The bottom line is we tend
to use our memory much less
later in life than we
do earlier in life.
So this is a large part of
the reason why your memory
ability starts to
decline as you get older.
It's because as your aging,
you are separating yourself
more and more from those early
years where you were constantly
using your memory.
The good aspect to this,
the positive aspect
is that if you make it a
point to exercise your memory,
actually use it,
it can stay strong
and actually even get
better, really, at any age.
Some people don't believe
me when I tell them this.
They're stuck on this idea
that someone later in years
is going to have a memory worse
than someone earlier in years.
They think that's
just the way it is.
So I like to talk about when
I competed in the World Memory
Championship, so I represented
the United States in the World
Memory Championship in
the Middle East in 2008.
I competed against
the guy-- when
I represented the US--
I competed against a guy
from Malaysia who, at the
time, was in his late 60s,
so more than 30
years older than me.
And he absolutely destroyed
me in the World Memory
Championship.
I was nowhere close to that guy.
He actually memorized
an entire dictionary.
And they would call
out any page number
in the dictionary
and the row number,
and within a few seconds
he could tell you the word
there and its definition.
He can also do the reverse.
If you said chair, he
would think about it
for a few seconds,
say oh, chair.
I think that's on
page 875, row three,
and he was right
every single time.
His name is Dr. Yip Swee Chooi.
He's known as the
walking dictionary.
He's from Malaysia.
But it just goes to
show that really you
can have a razor sharp memory
ability really at any age,
even after retirement age, 65,
usually the age people retire.
You can still have
awesome memory ability,
but he's always
working on his memory.
He's constantly training it.
That's why it stays very sharp.
So memory ability.
One benefit.
You are also going to improve
your visualization ability
with this type of training.
You will notice
that you are going
to be able to create
these images in your mind
much more quickly,
and you will be
able to see the imagery in
your mind much more clearly.
Visualization ability
has been linked
to more than just memory.
In fact, it's been linked
to overall intelligence.
If you can visualize the complex
relationships between things,
it helps to give you a
better understanding.
Visualization
ability's something
very important to develop.
You will develop it with
this type of training.
This is also great exercise
in creativity and imagination.
Coming up with these creative
and imaginative stories.
In addition, this is a very
good workout for your brain.
And all of the
research is showing
that we should try to
exercise our brains as much as
possible throughout
our lifetimes.
The research is
showing that if you
are destined to develop
Alzheimer's or another form
of dementia down the road,
with current research
they have no clue how to
prevent that from happening.
But what they do believe is that
by engaging in rigorous brain
exercise, you can
build up what they're
calling a cognitive reserve.
So that's the
terminology that you
would find in the research,
cognitive reserve.
But basically, what this
means is building up
extra brain muscle.
And if you do develop
Alzheimer's, another form
of dementia down the
road, the disease
will first have to eat away
at that extra brain muscle
before it starts to
affect your everyday life.
So what they're
saying is you can
gain more years
of mental clarity
that you would not have had
otherwise without this reserve.
So that's another benefit
of this type of training.
In terms of applications, in
just a very short presentation
like this, random words
is the easiest thing
to go with because it just gives
you an idea of how this all
works, and you get a
sense of how powerful
these techniques really are.
But I want to impress upon
you the fact that really,
these memory techniques can be
applied to committing to memory
anything at all that you
would want to remember.
You can easily give a speech
or a presentation from memory
without looking at notes.
You can commit to memory
important business related
facts and figures.
If you can meet with
clients or get up
in front of your colleagues
and give a presentation all
from memory, with everything
at your mental fingertips,
you are much more
impressive and you
seem like much more of an
expert in your particular field,
as opposed to
someone that's just
reading the PowerPoints
the whole time,
or just reading their
notes the whole time.
In addition, the bottom
line is that we perceive
people with great memory ability
as being more intelligent.
That's the perception.
So you can help to give off that
perception with memory skills.
So that's another benefit.
You can build up a vocabulary in
a foreign language very quickly
and easily using these
types of memory techniques.
Any type of exam that
involves a memorization
of a lot of terminology,
concepts, you
can easily ace
those types of exams
with these memory techniques.
There are really
limitless applications,
but I'm going to close
my presentation today
with my most popular topic
and that is remembering names
and faces, because this
is applicable, really,
in any career.
Definitely applicable to
everyone's personal life.
I like to quote the
famous book, "How
To Win Friends and
Influence People."
In that book it was written
that the sweetest sound
to a person in any language is
the sound of their own name.
And also, that everyone's
favorite subject is themself.
So in fact, by remembering
people's names and other things
about them, you can
build better business
and personal relationships.
The most important
thing of all to remember
is the person's name.
It's about building a
rapport with someone.
If you meet someone at an
event and the next time
you see him you can say
hey, John, how are you?
How is your wife Nancy?
How was your last round of golf?
What that person
is feeling, even
if it may be on a
subconscious level, is it
they must be pretty
important to you
if you can remember their name
and those things about them.
And that, in turn, makes them
want to get to know you better.
OK, so this strengthens
relationships.
The most important
thing is the name.
The opposite is also true.
If you're not remembering
people's names,
or maybe even worse,
you're calling them
by the wrong name,
what they are feeling
is that they must not be
very important to you,
and this can be very
detrimental to business
and personal relationships.
So how do you get
better at doing this?
Four simple steps.
First, independent of memory
techniques, and then I'll
get into a visual-based
memory technique after that.
Step number one.
From this day forward, get
into the habit, whenever
you are introduced to
someone, make it a point
to repeat the name right away
and shake the hand if you can.
So if you're introduced
to someone named Jared,
shake his hand.
Nice to meet you, Jared.
Pleased to meet you, Jared.
Just get into that habit.
That forces you to pay
attention for at least one
to two seconds in order for you
to be able to repeat the name.
A lot of times we're not
remembering people's names
because when they're
giving us their name,
we're just not paying any
attention to begin with.
So get into that habit.
Repeat the name, shake the hand.
Eventually it will just
become second nature to you.
Step number two.
Early on in your
interaction with the person,
ask them a question
using their name.
So Jared, how long have
you been with Google?
Jared, how long have
you known Chester?
How do you know Chester, Jared?
Use the name early on in your
interaction with the person.
That's really going
to help that name
stick much better in
your mind and prevent it
from just going in one
ear and out the other ear.
Step number three.
Take a few seconds
or less to think
of a connection between the
name and anything at all
that you already know.
And I would just go
with the first thing
that pops into your head.
Today it was Jared from Subway.
I don't-- that's the
first one, sorry.
That's the first thing that
popped into my head today.
AUDIENCE: I used to use the
jewelry store, but that's OK.
CHESTER SANTOS: OK.
Whatever, just think
of a connection
between the person's
name and anything at all
that you already know.
It could even actually
be that you just
have a friend or family member
that also has that same name.
It's really going to help you to
remember that name much better.
Step number four.
Whenever you leave the
party, the meeting,
whatever type of
function it may be,
make it a point to say goodbye
to people using their name.
Great meeting, hope to see
you again sometime, Jared.
Something like that.
That's going to go a long way
towards helping you to remember
those names the next
time you see people.
Those four steps alone
are going to help
you a lot in terms
of remembering names.
If you combine them with
a visual-based technique
that I'll now briefly go
over, you will definitely
be remembering more names
than you ever have before.
You might not be 100%.
Even I'm not 100%.
But if you can remember 80+% of
the people that you're meeting,
this is really going to pay
huge dividends in your career
and in your personal life.
Visual-based technique.
When you are introduced
to someone, ask yourself,
how does this person
in some way, any way,
look unique to you?
It could be a particular
facial feature
or it could be something
about their look overall.
And you want to exaggerate
that in your mind, whatever
it may be.
Next, you will use your
creativity and imagination
to come up with an image
that will in some way
remind you of the name, and you
will mentally link that image
to the unique thing
about the person.
A lot of times these might
not be flattering things--
you're not going to
be telling people
how you're remembering
their name, OK.
This is all going on
inside of your head.
They're not going to know
what you're thinking,
they're just going
to know that you're
able to call them by their
name and they will really
appreciate that fact.
I will quickly give you an
example of how this works.
I will give you the
example that I gave on CNN.
So I was interviewed on
CNN's "American Morning,"
and asked to give
tips for their viewers
on how to better remember names.
They seemed to find this
example pretty humorous.
No offense to anyone
in here named John.
I didn't meet anyone
named John yet,
but-- So it obviously
doesn't apply to you
because I haven't even met you.
But I said that if I
meet a particular John,
and this particular
John that I'm meeting,
has ears that to me look like
they're on the large side,
I would exaggerate those as
being gigantic Dumbo-like ears,
swinging from the
side of his head.
And since the
name's John, I might
put a toilet bowl
flushing in each ear,
as in going to the john.
The news anchors, they
couldn't stop laughing.
And then actually, that clip
also made it on VH1's best week
ever afterward.
If you take five seconds to
picture an image like that,
it's really going to stick
very well in your minds.
The next time you see
the guy, instantly you're
going to know that
his name is John.
I know it sounds
a little unusual,
but it's very powerful, and
anyone can get very good
at doing this with just
a little bit of practice.
[APPLAUSE]